for seven hours on monday for billions
of facebook's customers no likes no
insta moments no worldwide phone calls
or messaging
facebook's chief technology officer
needed twitter to tell customers it was
having massive technical difficulties
and then he apologized
facebook services coming back online now
may take some time to get to 100 percent
to every small and large business family
and individual who depends on us i'm
sorry
the outage also shut down operations at
facebook's california headquarters
no phones no computers some workers
reportedly using zoom to hold meetings
it's a good reminder the internet is
incredibly fragile it actually can have
problems like this arise and not work
for long periods typically we don't
really experience it much anymore it
used to be a lot more common like a
decade ago
some found the outage at facebook
instagram and whatsapp funny but for
whatsapp users analysts say the
disruption could have been catastrophic
whatsapp is tremendously important for
communication in a lot of parts of the
globe and it does raise questions around
you know how important it is for there
to be redundancy but also questions
around you know should private companies
be solely in control of infrastructure
so critical to communications and the
outage comes as facebook is under fire
for how it does business
u.s regulators say facebook is a
monopoly and should be broken apart a
move the company opposes facebook knows
last week senators grilled a facebook
official about a whistleblower's
allegations the company refuses to block
hate speech bullying and other forms of
harmful messaging from its sites
that whistleblower just gave her first
tv interview explaining why she thinks
this is the case
the thing i saw at facebook over and
over again was there were conflicts of
interest
between what was good for the public
and what was good for facebook
and facebook over and over again chose
to optimize for its own interests like
making more money facebook denies
francis hoggins allegations saying quote
to suggest we encourage bad content and
do nothing is just not true
but the company's efforts to build on
the public's trust now face another
hurdle hoggin testifies before congress
about facebook on tuesday
rosalind jordan al jazeera washington
facebook's share price had dropped by
almost five percent when markets closed
on monday rob mcbride's joining us from
hong kong where trading's just resumed
what are the markets looking like there
now
well there has been this big sell-off uh
on wall street overnight contributed to
of course by a tech stocks heading
downwards and that's had the spillover
effect into asia as trading has started
uh especially given the heavy weighting
of technical stocks on the asian markets
but it's also been contributed to by
fears of over inflation and that's been
stoked by the rising oil price and the
decision by
opec oil producing countries to increase
output but not by as much as people had
wanted so there are real concerns about
a rising oil price uh economies kicking
back into gear after the pandemic and
then with this rising gold price leading
possibly to inflation so we've seen
markets such as the nikkei in japan down
by three and a half percent at one point
although it has now rebounded the cosby
in south korea down two and a half
percent and then in taipei and here in
hong kong on the hang seng index both
indices heading towards one percent down
but again rebounding you do have here in
asia other factors which uh play on the
uh market and market sentiment such as
the ongoing uh dispute between the
tensions between china and the us and
then also other localized factors bigger
such as the coal shortage in china which
is impacting now on production and then
other factors such as the evergrande
crisis the saga of this uh large
conglomerate which is ongoing here in in
hong kong yeah let's talk about
evergrande i mean that's just to remind
people that's the chinese construction
company and holding company it's got
huge debts there is a lot of speculation
about its future it just suspended its
trade trading in its chairs on the hong
kong market what what's the latest with
this
that's right people are talking about
this as possibly being china's lehman
moment referring back to lehman brothers
the massive investment bank in the u.s
that collapsed right at the start of the
2007-2008
economic meltdown because this is a
similarly troubled company it is china's
second biggest uh property company but
it has the dubious distinction of being
the world's most indebted company with
carrying debts of 300 billion dollars
which it has managed to amass over the
years i think as it has grown now it is
having real problems and has
increasingly in recent weeks of trying
to meet repayment deadlines on not only
the loan itself but just on interest as
they come up
on our due and it has in recent weeks
being selling off some of its assets
just to raise cash to and allow it to
meet uh these deadlines the latest
speculation is that it is about to sell
off a part of its property uh management
arm to another company uh that's listed
in hong kong so all of the the shares in
these companies have been suspended
while this is potentially going to take
place but it is a real concern because
it has uh it there is has interests in
various sectors throughout china so
there's real concern for the chinese
government about the contagion effect on
the rest of the economy it is suspected
of prodding government-backed and
government-controlled companies to buy
up some of evergran's assets to help it
out but the chinese government is
concerned not only about the economic
fallout but also the potential social
stability aspect of this because of
course evergrand has hundreds of
developments in cities across china some
of them are completed some of them are
half completed and there is a real
concern that if there was some sort of
collapse then there are will be
increasingly homeowners or people who
put down deposits who will not be happy
so there is a real social stability
concern for the chinese government and
there is
a pressure here for evergrand to settle
debts locally before it settles loans
with overseas entities rob thanks very
much indeed that's rob mcbride bringing
us up to date from hong kong